movie 43 so everyone was like what's
movie 43 about I was like what the hell
is movie 43 about here's what movie 43
is about nothing it's a bunch of
unrelated sketch comedy that's lined up
back-to-back to make a movie the thing
that gives it premise the thing that is
actually about is that Dennis Quaid's
pitching a script to a studio this
script is the movie we see it's horrible
it's supposed to be terrible so I get
that but when the joke in the movies
that this script is horrible and then
they make you watch the script in movie
form it's not funny I'm not along for
the joke I just have to watch a shitty
movie that you yourself recognize is
shitty why would you do that to us the
first five minutes of this movie you're
like is this gonna get better than the
next you know hour of the movie does not
get better I thought about walking out
of movie 43 but I was like no integrity
I will stick around right here you feel
that from me to you there were a couple
sketches that had their element of funny
in it the whole Robin sketch that was
pretty funny the funniest sketch in the
entire movies a Terrence Howard sketch
when you see it in the trailer - it's
the very last sketch of the entire movie
you know when I'm like an had it's cool
thing but I don't think sitting through
the entire movie was worth it I will
definitively tell you sitting through
the entire movie of movie 43 it's not
worth one sketch at the end that you
actually see a glimpse of in the trailer
I was just watching movie 43 and I was
like I've seen better sketch comedy on
YouTube you don't have to go that far
when you're done with this video you can
watch funnier sketches on YouTube the
website you're on right now gonna bum me
out I was like it sucks that these
people have the budget to make a movie
and they're not as funny as people who
do on YouTube for free it's clear that
movie 43 is this indulgent private joke
among just a few people who were talking
about Daniel Oh that'd be funny if it
was in a movie hey we have money why
don't we just put it in a movie but now
it's theatrically released which almost
implies that other people are supposed
to now be on board with their own
private joke and it's not they won't be
nothing magical happens when the movie
comes to theatres if it starts out as a
private joke it's still a private joke a
couple of things I did get what they
were going for us I are a Hugh Jackman
has like balls on his neck
like actual balls and he's on a date
with Kate Winslet this movie has a
pretty legit cast so there is that I'm
glad they can all you know make bad
career decisions and not even look back
me like yeah I can do that I can afford
this [ __ ] good for you guys but he has
balls on his neck it's this metaphor
about or when you're on a date with
someone in you're nervous and [ __ ]
you're going to nitpick and look for
things that aren't there and is this
like seeing balls on someone's Mac that
being said just wasn't funny just a guy
with balls on his neck it sounds funnier
now and I'm explaining it than it
actually is when you're watching it it's
like the great be mad TV that's right
movie 43 is the grade B version of a
show that was cancelled for not being
that funny think about that [ __ ] the
people who will connect with this movie
are studio execs who get absurd scripts
pitched to them every day that people
actually think are good they're going to
be like oh I get how that is I've seen
scripts like that that's really funny I
I connect with this movie I'm point zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero one percent of humanity
but I connect with this movie the rest
of the world is gonna be left out in the
cold so I'm telling you guys I will say
movie 43 is dog [ __ ] not being nice for
the sake of being nice watch funnier
sketch on YouTube like I said somewhat
some funny-ass sketch comedy that you
like whatever it is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you